anyone today that's impostor a bunch of
times like you have a chance
okay we got some bad cremates is that
what you're saying
we got some bad what cremates is that
the implication we got bad detectives
uh yes and yes
nice little mix of both oh garrett i'm
loving your flower
that is that is oh thank you all right
bring it on green here we go
jeff and you forget to
love to see it ladies and gentlemen this
is what i love to see the problem is
um that i can see all of their faces
so i'm going to try not to look and i'm
going to try not to be too expressive
damien what are you damien damien
hey i think i'm gonna be all right
get up let me just line this up
all right somebody else can deal with
that this isn't i have no beef with your
kind
i i'm just trying to get my toss done
he's trying to do a good job it's not a
problem
hey bud hello hi hello hey there i feel
like i'm getting through these
pretty quickly if i'm being honest
okay but i've also seen
absolutely nothing
courtney it'd be great to have someone
watch me do med bay
that would be really handy oh it's this
one never mind disregard
okay this is the one where i have to
wait [ __ ] two hours
how are we getting these stars done so
fast somebody's gotta be dead
courtney courtney courtney courtney
courtney
right surely okay
well that makes me think courtney is
probably
oh well okay
ah okay
sarah we're gonna we're gonna talk about
how you were just walking down
the pathway where the dead body was we
gonna have a chat about that at all
what yeah so there's a dead body that's
like right down the hallway from reactor
i was in electrical with
uh courtney and then went out and walked
up and then you were just coming down
from where there was a body right from
somewhere where you would have had to
afford i
i didn't see a body that checks out your
body
what were you what were you up to then
uh i was going to
med bay because also i took my band-aids
off my thumbs and so they're all sticky
and because my homes are sticky yeah
remember how i don't have fingertips
remember so i had band-aids on my thumbs
and
i kept slipping all over the place but i
was going towards
no no the bad news sarah is that you
like almost could have got away with it
but what you were doing was walking
down not up i'm sorry you definitely
murdered me i thought no
because literally my thumb was being no
i'm sorry you murdered big jungles
no i don't know alana you're coming so
strong
i don't i don't know i never saw a body
no you did though because you killed
them and then you walked right past them
but it would have been impossible for
you not to have seen it
i'm sorry it wasn't even there's two
there's two
dead bodies there's big jungles your boy
big jungus
dead because of your thumbs apparently
jack i did not kill
jungus i don't need i didn't even see a
body all right well everyone else it
doesn't make any sense that she was
walking down from where her body was
had to evoke past it and then said she
was actually walking up when she was not
no i was i was walking down because my
thumbs i saw you i saw courtney
pull for your thumbs that's a new one
yeah i have i don't have i don't have
fingertips but that big jungle is dead
so can i ask you why you don't have
fingertips yes
my skin's very weak but i've gone to the
dermatologist my whole life and they
don't know what
yeah and i usually sometimes have
band-aids on all my fingers because all
my fingers
what are we doing i mean that's pretty
metal i don't we're good we're good
i promise i promise let's check
all right um so anyone who's played this
game with me will now know
that um i know that the other one is
damien okay
if you guys have ever watched my streams
you will know
that the tell for the other one
when you are accusing someone correctly
is when they go okay so what are we
doing
um if they go so what are we doing in
the first round
uh it is only impostors ever say that um
because crewmates never base what
they're doing on what
other crewmates are doing um
so you know problem solved same but i
don't think that i could run to the
button and make a case because i don't
know these people well enough to do that
oh hello hey i found shane's body right
outside of coms
if people don't know where that is
that's bottom bottom of the map
almost like to the bottom right almost
on the way i was on my way to
the hexagon one yeah um no hexagon is
shielded
i didn't see anybody
so just saw alana run by me right
uh before this nobody was called running
down the left yeah
yeah yeah alana was with me for like
going the same way
um okay damian what were you up to just
curious
this is gonna sound ridiculous but i was
at shields and then
as o2 went off i went up so i know
that's damning but i would have made up
a better life
i'm damian because he was against voting
for courtney
so i have this one rule that anytime in
the first round
if a crewmate says okay so what are we
doing um
that person is the imposter uh
so the minute that that happened and
damian was like so what are we doing i
was like cool so
uh it's it's sarah and it's damian um
because because
because crewmates don't do that
crewmates never
like what is everyone else voting for uh
they just do their own votes so i but we
don't have any proof but
if the rule is correct again then it's
[ __ ] david
so the only people that were coming from
that this area at the time was aaron and
alana
no i was know any other no we were no i
was over by reactor
alana and garrett corroborate being on
the left side i saw alana over there
so that means garrett was over there
jackie you've been a little quiet
what were you up to i was in o2 so i
right when i finished putting the code
in that's when the dead body was
reported
where did you come from from o2 though
where did you go um
i i was i was
i saw you run down damien when i was an
admin and then after admin i went over
to o2 because that's when
the sabotage started i'm positive it's
not courtney
she could have killed me in electrical
like two separate times and nothing
happened yeah we were by each other a
lot
yeah um well it's definitely not me
and it's not i mean
it's a great argument i'm skipping
i didn't know the rules that's right
every time i've said that as a crew
right every time many times
okay oh am i done i am done
well now we just kind of wait
okay we can hang out hey what are you
doing you guys want to just chill
who has not done that toss maybe ghosts
maybe ghosts have done their tasks
i'm just gonna you know just hang out
have a good time
if i'm wrong about it being damien and
it's spencer that's gonna look real bad
for me
that would really i'd really get get
[ __ ] there but hopefully
we're fine okay we do have to go do that
uh damien have you killed anyone yet
are you trying to separate us
okay
well
we're trying to get a stack or something
it's totally him come on why why else
would he split up unless he's not done
his tasks but
but i it legit every single time i've
called that it's been correct so i don't
know
are we just gonna give
damian like a real tough time here like
what's the plan
do the tasks are so close that's like
one more person's task
okay all right
we do need to go do oxygen we do need to
hope that debut doesn't kill anybody in
the process of doing oxygen
oh okay i've got spencer here i'm gonna
be fine six
one six two one thing
okay now just stay with spencer
there you go where did you go it's
better hey guys
hey guys what's up oh jackie's here too
we haven't seen jackie very much
is so funny
oh good okay yeah we could go do lights
we going this way
all right come on gang
[ __ ] you gonna try and swipe someone in
here or something damien
oh i'm alone oh okay
i think we're fine yeah
wow was it damian nice yeah it was
yeah it's like fiddlesticks i'm sorry
we finished all the tasks yeah we made
that really hard for you at the end by
just sticking in a group the whole time
we're playing some hard d yeah bro you
don't want to lie that i kind of carried
us
oh my god